a
si no ha empezado su periodo vacacional
más relevante del calendario nacional en
un estado de semi normalidad aquí no
están vigentes las normas de
distanciamiento social pero tampoco se
ha producido el éxodo masivo que cada
año lleva a centenares de millones de
chinos a atravesar el país para reunirse
con sus familiares la razón es el
rebrote del norte del país en enero ya
sofocado pero que fue el pero en 10
meses y contó con más de 2000 casos eso
empujó al gobierno a desaconsejar todos
los viajes que no fueran estrictamente
necesarios y las autoridades dieron
descuentos en restaurantes en
atracciones turísticas locales
e incluso dinero en efectivo eso ha
conseguido que los viajes se hayan
reducido en un 60% con respecto a los
del año 2019 en pekín el templo del lama
ha estado cerrado ahí es donde se juntan
miles de chinos en el primer día del año
para quemar incienso y pedir buenos
deseos y también estaba cerrado el
tradicional mercado de comida del templo
de titan en pekín ha sido un día
grisáceo y pesado para dar la bienvenida
al año del buey
[Música]
la ciudad de nueva york ha querido
unirse a las celebraciones del año nuevo
chino bajo el signo del buey y durante
la noche estará iluminando sus edificios
más emblemáticos como por ejemplo el
oculus que están viendo detrás de mí o
la torre del famoso world trace center
además también se iluminará el edificio
más conocido en esta ciudad el empire
state que además estará ofreciendo
también una exposición en la quinta
avenida sobre la cultura china que
mantendrá hasta el próximo 10 de marzo
además se espera que los restaurantes
asiáticos de la ciudad estén ofreciendo
estos días un menú especial para las
celebraciones y que los estadounidenses
de origen chino se reúnan en las casas
para celebrar este año nuevo eso sí los
expertos advierten que siguiendo siempre
las medidas de seguridad por el kobe 19
[Música]
los coloridos festejos y los desfiles
que todos los años se realizan en
londres y en otras ciudades de
inglaterra para darle la bienvenida al
nuevo año chino se realizarán por
primera vez online dado que este país
continúa en su tercer confinamiento
nacional y las cifras de infección con
hobbits siguen siendo muy altas la de
londres se considera que es una de las
celebraciones más grandes fuera de
países asiáticos las calles del
chinatown han sido decoradas con el
tradicional rojo y con luces pero este
sector de el centro de la capital
británica está prácticamente vacío
algunos restaurantes se mantienen
abiertos pero solo para domicilios en su
tradicional mensaje para la comunidad
china
el primer ministro boris johnson dijo
que como el buey esta bestia fuerte y
perseverante el mundo seguirá en su
lucha en su batalla para derrotar al cob
y 19
[Música]